trois mois après le drame il reste
marqué par leurs interventions sur
l'autoroute 4,40
ce que j'ai entendu en premier c'est
célèbre ruisseau il terminait à peine
leur quart de travail quand sur le
chemin du retour derrière leur ambulance
un carambolage
on s'est mis sur le côté on a reculé le
plus proche qu'on pouvait je débarque
je me rends compte que ça commence à
flamber un véhicule brute sous un camion
remorque s'est approché du véhicule qui
était en flammes puis j'entendais le
monde dans la voiture qui appelait à
l'aide
j'avais plus de voix fait je l'appelais
je l'appelais je voyais juste les
flammes qui m'a suis resté l'homme il
forcé avec la cour avec la cour
pierre magne est allé chercher ont pu
rester à fait impossible de sauver les
deux passagers d'un premier véhicule en
flammes
il se tourne alors vers une autre
voiture où sont coincés des enfants
mépris qu'on s'éloigne un peu parce
qu'avec comics and que la titraille
criaient s'essoufflait abandonné ne pas
laisser ma peau ici
puis on y lisait ce port est qu'à
d'autres souvent la seule fois quand on
est retournés par les chercher avec des
policiers on est sorti mais c'est
seulement temps d'un enfant comme ceux
qui crient de calabar donné par l'actu
les flancs l'homme quand commence à
s'approcher la voiture tout de suite
après la tragédie
la paire aidantes annie claude guy les a
rencontrés urgences-santé compte 36
techniciens ambulanciers formé comme
père est dans ils interviennent auprès
de collègues impliqués dans des
événements traumatisants les paierai
d'un fonds ont suivi quelques jours plus
tard les ai rappelés 24 heures 48 heures
après pour savoir et puis comment la
première nuit était ce qui permet
d'identifier les cas plus complexes
comme marc andré et mathieu mais parle
beaucoup avec mathieu c'était normal
qu'une seule à faire des cauchemars à me
réveiller la nuit à repenser encore
rasta singla les bus tél
la honte la honte la culpabilité j'avais
la difficulté 1 en parler ma famille
voulait me parler je retourne après deux
appels je n'ai pas le choix je me disais
toujours ils vont penser que j'étais là
où c'est pas rationnel il pouvait pas
faire plus on sait tous ce sentiment de
culpabilité a pu être identifiée plus
rapidement grâce aux programmes de prêt
d'en instituer en 2018
il donne déjà des résultats on a des
absences pour motif puisque le gic
reliés au stress qui sont beaucoup moins
longue
parce qu'une bonne prise en charge une
diminution de 20 % de la durée des
congés de maladies liées au stress avec
les traitements les médecins qu'on a vu
en est sa bonne voie on voit la
progression
mathieu et marc andré se rétablisse peu
à peu pour la première fois depuis la
tragédie du mois d'où ils ont réussi à
enfiler l'uniforme avant notre entrevue
c'est sûr on va vendre son âme lens on
va travailler ensemble puis ans
on peut continuer la même job conteuse
et les deux ensemble en équipe ici david
gêne-t-il et radio canada dit mon frère